[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana tala Salam alikum guys so
basically brother and sisters we just
got news I came to Zan's house and we
got some news uh that Iran has um fired
300 ballistic missiles I've got the
footages here I don't know if you want
to watch it with me and Israel is going
ballistic yes launch at least 300
ballistic missiles to many is real
cities yo yo yo yo
[Music]
hey y
push many
men wish death upon
me anyway so what do you make out of it
Subhan Allah like after the the killing
of
um I think for a very long time yeah
regardless of whatever side you're on
the thing is Palestinians plight is on
the Forefront of everyone's
Consciousness and you know what there's
a sense of frustration why doesn't a
single Muslim leader stand up and do
something yeah and people can debate
about it's this reason or that reason
but no one no one was raising a finger
towards Israel let alone the missiles
and the thing is anytime we say this is
happening to Palestinians and this and
they say it's Warfare this is what
happens in in war so yeah if you're in
war then this is this is what happens
why you moaning why are you complaining
about oh we're under attack hey it's War
you have invaded Palestine you have now
been invading Lebanon and you've done
Syria as well and you know we all know
about the intentions of Greater Israel
and the expansionist yes may Allah
destroy them yeah the expansionist
Endeavors that they want to do it's not
as simple as they just one little
little box in the Middle East like let
them have that little box no the
intentions of Greater Israel it's not a
conspiracy yeah and they are looking to
expand and they're constantly poking but
it's okay because the the defense or
whatever it is it's all being funded by
the taxpayers here in the UK into Europe
and in America as well so exactly I mean
um like I mean we're going to see how
long our freedom of speech allows us to
on like this because um the words that
were saying some of them will even they
were try to twist it you know this is
what we're talking about the hypocrisy
that you guys have you don't believe in
freedom of speech it's absolute bull
crap okay it's absolutely bull crap
because there's certain things that if
we was to say we would probably be
arrested yes okay so it shows you don't
believe in know down freedom of speech
you flipping Hypocrites you flipping
double sand Hypocrites number two what
I'm noticing is the attacks from the
houis in Yen um even from Iraq um even
from Iran and from hisbah for some odd
reasons why I hear when I hear from the
news is that they are hitting uh
military basis they are hit and I'm like
hold hold on a second I mean these these
guys are some well depends no refugee
camps no no no no nothing like that no
schools or hospital no no no this is
what I find very bizarre because no un
or journalists no no nothing like that
it's bizarre that the Democracy in the
only democracy in the Middle East which
is massacring Children Killing
journalists killing people killing
British and American citizens yes and
then you're talking about Israel has a
right to defend itself I forgot the our
allies and yes and a democracy that's it
you should have Tau me that before you
me that allies of the West now it
changes it now it justifies what they're
doing you flipping scumbags yes you can
see these individuals who are Terror
terrorist organizations the depends on
what part of which countries determine
them no problem let's go with that how
come these terrorist organization let's
go with argument sake they are terrorist
organizations yeah hisbah
Hamas Iran and by the way Iran regime
like I'm I do not support them in any
way shape or form yet when it comes to
certain certain things but for some OD
reason they're the terrorist Oran
orations terrorism the definition
terrorism is what killing innocent
people for political gains but they
attack army bases and even when it came
to what Hamas said 7 October which the
1200 people majority of them killed um
was killed by who the Hannibal directive
by Israel's army they killed their own
people man they M their own people even
then they were attacking who um military
personnel yes they went for military
personnel and if they was to kill anyone
that's innocent we condemn it because
our religion tells us to condemn it so
to me to see this at attack and it's
targeting military bases this is what
you call War because okay you're going
for military bases War happens but no
way can you come and justify and say
okay innocent people are being killed oh
it's War what the are you talking about
man in look if it was in very certain
specific circumstances not nearly 20,000
kids being killed that's not specific
circumstance bro do you get what I'm
trying to say so I this is update we
want to give you guys 300 ballistic
missiles were sent to uh Israel and let
me be honest as as a gift or whatever is
from their side this is what what
they're doing um and it was sent and to
be honest with me I want to see the end
of the Zionist regime the end of Israel
not of the Jews it makes very clear the
Jews and the Muslims and the Christians
should gr will be living back in those
lands in the Palestinian land it's
actually anti-semitic to link Israel to
Jews and Judaism it's like linking Isis
to Islam or Muslims yeah because not not
everyone supports the current regime not
everyone supports what's going on and
because of that to to link a ageold
religion to you were atheist well
benorian yeah he was an atheist um one
of the first um Prime Ministers even
Benjamin bastard he's he's an atheist so
how could you connect that to Judaism so
to me like I said before may Allah look
oppression never ever you go look if
there's oppression in the land you are
never going to live in peace and may you
never live in peace I say this directly
anyone that's Zionist may you guys never
live in peace
whoever it is whoever oppress anyone
yeah even if you're an oppressor I don't
care peace is not meant for you it's
literally as simple as that you never
sleep in peace man never ever and the
thing is that the the sooner America and
the Western allies of Israel back off
and let Israel understand the
consequences of their own actions the
better it will be for you as well why
are you poking your noses and okay with
your tax money going to this country
that literally is leeching off you
they're parasites exactly bro it's
unbelievable what have they actually
done for the UK and America what has
Israel done not only that alhamdulillah
the Americans are waking up to this
reality that's why people like Candace
Owens and many of them B yes they're
waking up bro they saying hold on a
second what the f is going on man you're
using our money where there's flipping
starvation drug abuse homelessness
people starving death in America they
even the UK you're cutting flipping
labor cutting uh funding to elderly
people freeing to death according to
Donald Trump who's let's face it most
likely to become the next leader
he's saying in Springfield they're
eating cats and dogs I mean if you're
the guy that's saying you know you know
what we have to support Israel and they
vying with each other to say we love
Israel more with Kamala Harris and she's
saying no I love Israel more and there's
this tussle happening then if your
people are eating cats and dogs
shouldn't you be using those billions
and keeping it in your country and
reinvesting it like what has Israel done
for you they are useless their time
inshah is very limited may Allah subh
deal with oppressors may Allah in
Destroy them in this life and in the
Hereafter th one of the updat want to
give you guys Islam net is raising funds
to establish a Masjid and Community
Center in Norway and they urgently need
your support every person who prays
there every kid that learns about Islam
every youngster that memorize the Quran
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of Good Deeds click the link
and donate what you can and share the
video for even extra reward